Hey everyone, it's Mike from Orderflows
here and welcome back to my channel. You
know, in today's video, I'll be talking
about the value areas in each bar and a
new feature that we have on the
orderflows trader software that makes uh
that differentiates the value areas that
uh we feel are more uh stronger um
because they're exhibiting signs of
accumulation or distribution. All right.
So, um, before we jump in, you know, if
you you enjoy my channel, be sure to hit
the like button and subscribe to the
channel so that whenever I do post a new
video. Um, it's getting to be
summertime, I should have some free time
to get some more videos out for you
guys. Uh, you'll be notified of when we
uh when I post them. All right. So, on
the Orderflows Trader software, you'll
see that uh we have a function on there
to highlight the value area of the bar.
All right. So, you just scroll down
here, and I already have it turned on,
but you see it's right here. value area.
And I have it, you could draw it out
until tested or just keep it tested. And
the value area of each bar. If it's a
down candle, it's going to be red. If
it's an up candle, it's going to be
green. So, it's going to match the color
of the bar. And you see here, right, we
have um this green candle here with this
value area that's colored green. We have
a red candle with a red value area. And
you know, all the value area is, it's
where 70% of the volume of the bar
traded. Okay? It's it's not some fancy
algorithm. I mean, it's a basic concept
that comes from market profile um you
know, then was uh popularized more in
volume profile. And again, you know,
every bar that trades that has volume is
going to have a value area. You know, in
E- Minis, uh you do have a nice range.
In some of the slower markets, you're
going to get uh you know, a smaller,
tighter value area sometimes just
because the way volume is distributed.
Now, the way I like to trade value
areas, right, because what is a value
area? Well, it's the area where the
majority of the volume in a bar traded.
And oftent times what you're going to
see is sort of value areas that are
overlapping, right? That
are covering several prices over several
bars. Like you could see right here, we
got um this bar at 8:41 this morning.
It's covered 1 2 3 4 with the bar at
842. The bar at 842 covers 1, two, three
price levels in this bar at 843. Okay.
Then the next bar opens up outside above
the value area. Doesn't trade back into
the value area at 843. Stays above that,
then we have a nice rally. Okay? And
what we call that is we call that an
abandoned value area. you know, if
you're sort of a if you're a market
profile follower, um the you're familiar
with the term naked point of control,
virgin point of control or even naked
value area or or virgin value area. I
call them abandoned because the market
is moving away from that established
um value. Okay. Now, where it gets
interesting is, you know, when when you
look for the market to trace trade back
to a previous value area because in
theory, right, if you have an area that
was established as value and the market
moves away from it and eventually comes
back to that area, oftent times um
you're going to look for it to see if it
can hold as support or resistance. Okay?
Now the problem is you see sometimes we
just blow right through these levels
right these red levels right these are
abandoned value areas um you know you
have some bullish one here bullish one
here we sort of come down um and you
know while in general it it does make
nice support or resistance
areas what I've done is you I've done a
lot of analysis on the value area itself
and I realized that some value areas
actually exhibit signs of accumulation
or distribution. Accumulation is
obviously um you know people building up
a position. Distribution is people
getting a position off their books so to
speak, right? They're distributing their
position out.
And what I've done, so since I was able
to identify those value areas that
exhibit accumulation or distribution,
what we do is we highlight them a
different color as opposed to just the
normal green or red. So on the
settings, let's pull it up here. Okay,
you just scroll down and there's another
function in
there. It's called value area
absorption. So you just uh click that
and you can draw it until tested. Now
the colors for bullish value area
absorption is dark blue. Bearish value
area absorption is is deep pink.
Now we're going to get into a little
semantic argument here and people will
throw stones at me because they'll say
it's not right. If it's bearish value
area absorption in theory it's really
bearish value area distribution. I'm
just using the term absorption because
most more people are are more familiar
with that. But it is the opposite of
absorption, right? When I talk about
valueary absorption and distribution, um
they have the same thing but on
opposite, you know, 180 degrees, you
know, opposite ends of the spectrum. So,
you're going to look for the dark blue
or the deep pink um value areas. Okay?
They in my opinion are going to be more
powerful than just the regular value
areas that I'm looking at to be support
or resistance. I'm going to look for the
bullish or bearish value absorption as
acting more as support or resistance.
Okay. So you can see in here right this
one if
it is a bullish or bearish sign of value
area absorption like I said it's going
to color
that value area and the zone that's
generated from the value area if we
don't trade back into it right blue if
it's bullish or deep pink if it is
bearish. You can see this one is
holding. Okay. Um, you see this is just
a normal value area, right? That's why
it's still green, right? We came back
down, we traded down through it. Here
you have a bullish uh value area
absorption. Market came traded into it,
rallied off that. Here is a normal
bearish one, bearish value area. You
know, the market did trade back up to it
and sell off, but then we had an bearish
value area
absorption/distribution. See, the market
came right up to it and then traded off
of it. Okay. Um, you know, I I just I I
wanted a way, you know, cuz I I noticed,
you know, in in my research that, you
know, some value areas hold better than
others. And and what what was the
reason, you know, I I wanted to find out
why. And I like to think I came up with
a pretty good reason why. Um, it's
because there's distribution taking
place like in this value area or
accumulation taking place here. Okay,
just going through, right? This is your
bearish
distribution, right? You can see we
traded right up to the bottom of it and
came off a little bit. Um, you know,
this just your normal value area that's
not traded into. Same with this one.
Okay. Now, what I'm really focusing on
is the value areas that are abandoned,
right? Where they're not traded into in
the next bar. That is your trigger in a
sense. If the next bar doesn't trade
back into
it, that's going to be, in my opinion, a
level to watch for when the market comes
back to it. So, I'm just finding some
other see if there's any other levels
here. Um, these are just normal ones.
Again, you see this is just a normal
one. Market traded down through it. This
was a normal one. Market traded through
it. This was a normal one. Market traded
through it. Okay. Here's one. It kind of
held. Market dipped down below. sort of
went
sideways, couple bearish ones. All
right, we traded up, got one tick
through it and sort of held and this is
where we are right now. But this
morning, um there's a beautiful one that
occurred right off of the open, cash
open, that is uh let me just find it
here. Okay, well there's a couple,
right? So this is the one where I
started with, but you know, you had a
bearish one here, sorry, a bullish one.
market came down into it, rallied up
that one we had, we talked about. But
look at this one
here, right almost off of right ahead of
the cash here. Nice bullish
accumulation in the value area. Traded
right into it. Market opens up and just
ran. Now again, you know, bars are going
to have value areas. So you can see
there's blue, right? indicating that
these are these bars are exhibiting the
signs
of bullish accumulation taking place
inside the value area. All
right,
but to me it's not important because we
are trading back into it in the next
bar. What I like to see is the market
move away from that value, not pull back
into it. All right. So, you know, even
though, you know, here's just your red
value area, just, you know, your green,
your red, your green, your red, your
green, green. That's just your normal
trading that's taking place. Like I
said, you know, every bar it's going to
have a value area, and most of the times
the value areas, the individual bars
aren't going to matter. The ones that
matter the most are the ones where the
market just starts moving away from that
established value. Okay?
um you know just as you have where's the
pink one here right this is let me just
pull this down a little bit you can see
there's potential value area
distribution taking place here but then
we just still trade around those areas
just as this one right what you're
looking for are those value areas that
the market starts to move away from and
potentially pulls back into right and if
it's a blue value area right you have
that blue zone you're looking for it to
hold. If it was a pink zone like this as
opposed to the red, you're going to look
for it to hold. And you know, I could
even, if I wanted to, I could even just
I could turn off the
zones for the normal value areas, so I'm
not
confused, especially if you're you're
just sort of getting started with them.
Um, you know, I like to keep the value
absorption until tested. The regular
value area
um just fixed fixed to that one bar
itself, right? I don't need to have it
drawn
out. Okay. So, hit okay. Just give it a
second to come up
here.
And 3 2 1 should come up. Uh there we
go. So, I can see I could just focus on
this. I can focus on this. I'm not being
distracted, right? I can focus on this.
Okay. What do I do? Well, I know the
value area high of this bar is 5954 and
a/4. I know the low is 51 and 3/4. What
do you want to do? Well, maybe I'll put
a buy in, you know, somewhere in the
middle of the bar, somewhere near the
top, somewhere near the bottom. Can sort
of average it out if I'm looking for the
market to pull back. Generally speaking,
you don't get necessarily deep pullbacks
into the value areas. They tend to be uh
concentrated a little bit more towards
the the top end. So, you know,
definitely keep it around the value area
high 54 and a quarter. this level, you
know, you can scale in with a tick here,
you know, maybe a tick here, and you can
see comes down, hits all three levels
there, right? Before moving back up. You
know, if you want a lowrisk
trade, you buy on one end of the value
area with a stop on the other with your
takeprofit way up here, right? I mean,
you're you're you're buying it at even
if you're just buying it at the value
area high or one tick above, call it
5954 and
a2, you know, maybe you got a stop down
here at, you know, we'll call it 51.
That's what 3 and 1/2 points. You went
from 4 and a half, you know, all the way
up into the 60s before you got a bearish
signal here. And again, now this one
traded right up to the value area low.
Didn't trade into it, but got one tick
there. That's why I say, you know, you
might want to just sort of go on the
value one tick above the value area high
or one tick below the value area low to
give you a trade because, you know,
imagine if you can short it in here at
67 and a half or a quarter or even 67.
You know, it trades all the way down
almost to 57. It got down to, you know,
58 more or
less before trading back up. Then it
finally traded back in there. But again,
you're not looking for it to trade in
there, come off, trade back in there.
You're looking for the first test. But
that uh that my friends is how to use
the value area absorption on order flows
trader. It's the only software that has
it because it's my own proprietary
algorithm that we designed to
specifically
find absorption in the value areas.
Okay. All right everyone. So thanks for
watching this. I'll see you guys on the
next video.